monsieur Serot oui avez-vous besoin d'un
guitariste oh oh Jacques Brell ça c'est
gentil oh merci d'être venu mais vous
savez que monsieur serro a toujours
besoin d'un guitariste je vous en prie
on vous
[Musique]
écoute quand on a cl
l'amour pour habiller
matin pauvres et
malendrins de manteau de velours quand
on a cl l'amour à offrir en prière pour
les MS de la terre en simple
trouadour quand on a que l'amour à
offrir à cela dont l'unique combat est
de chercher le jour quand on a que
l'amour pour tracer un chemin et forcer
le destin à chaque
carrefour quand on a que l'amour pour
parler au canon et rien qu'une chanson
pour convaincre un
tambour alors sans avoir rien que la
force d'aimer nous aurons dans nos mains
amis le monde
entier